rick et je pense que le plus beau cadeau
que je puisse te faire c'est que ce soir
tu ne t'occupes pas du public mais que
tu viennes rejoindre la table
[Applaudissements]
ces images de passer les réussites faire
la fête
bernard disait que c'était c'était pour
un l'occasion d'un anniversaire et
d'ailleurs c'était le mien c'est pour ça
que les latins soir c'est notre
chauffeur de salle il ne tournait à
table très bien eric tu sais quoi la
très bonne atteindre 130 a toujours été
plus drôle que tout le monde il ya 14
jours entre les deux tours de la
présidentielle il ya des dizaines de
sujets à aborder
il ya des publics différents à toucher
les jeunes qui votent peu les acteurs
économiques les plus influents les
retraités les travailleurs pourquoi on
fait qu'un débat depuis 1970 ces
quelques à côté de ça il faut un débat
qui avait cherché les jeunes qui les
intéressent à la chose politique qui les
amène au vote et qui permettent aussi
aux candidats de montrer des aspects de
leur personnalité que dans un débat plus
est plus classique il ne montre pas et
de ce côté là bas dans ce troisième
débat pourquoi pas pourquoi pas cyril
hanouna en effet j'ai remarqué je suis
vos émissions je regarde tous l'un d'eux
il ya plein de ministres ils sont venus
sur votre émission
ils ont dit plein de choses en fait
plein de promesses tous les cadeaux au
pied du sapin
et puis arrivée au conseil des ministres
ils n'ont pas tenu leurs promesses c'est
à dire qu'ils se disent en fait chez
cyril hanouna on dit n'importe quoi on
fait un petit coup de com
et puis dernier on tient pas il aurait
pas fait ça avec nathalie saint cricq
pas avec jean jacques bourdin pas avec
cela à sanaa mais quand on se souvient
du crash qui était celui de marine le
pen dans je vais au ciné débat hollande
de sarkozy avec ça parce que les
réactions
ça fait bien qu les élections irie et
donc s'il y a en face de vous un
candidat qui sort une fake news un
mensonge et que vous n'êtes pas assez
préparés sur un sujet où elle s'est calé
sur le sujet malheureusement sera pas
possible de le démasquer
déjà venu nous voir pour d'autres choses
sur ce plateau et là vous êtes un
collègue de stéphanie il ya eu à
première vue une attaque commissariat de
rambouillet et il y aurait une femme une
administrative de toucher donc
qu'est ce que j'ai fait de suite j'ai
téléphoné à l'administratif qui est à
l'accueil est une très proches amis
ce que j'avais pas que ça soit elle elle
me dit c'est stéphanie vous la
connaissez bien stéphanie c'était une
agent administratif qui gérait notamment
le courrier sur rambouillet elle était
fidèle à cette photo c'est à dire
toujours souriante
il a suffi qu'ils se saisissent de son
couteau qu'il tombe dessus lui a pas
laissé un instant viennent heureusement
j'ai un autre collègue qui était sur
place qui a pu faire usage de son arme
quasi instantanément neutraliser le
terroriste personne n'oblige bernard
tapie à quoi que ce soit depuis le début
et bernard tapie mais vous croyez
franchement non mais bernard tapie c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît la télévision
c'est quelqu'un quand il prend un
engagement il le tient aussi à voter non
d'abord on ne passe pas il a passé une
heure une heure et quart donc s'ils
étaient ils avaient vraiment bas en vie
il serait parti au bout d'un quart
d'heure
deuxièmement gilles verdez faut arrêter
quand même devenir n'importe quoi
franchement chaque fois que je viens ici
j'ai affaire à un con comme vous et je
vais vous dire une chose je j'ai un
combo et je vous dire une chose je vais
le répéter c'est pas très très gaie et
des oeufs
ce n'est pas très raffiné mais je vous
rappelle pierre desproges
il y parlait à un conte ou essayer de
convaincre c'est comme se masturber avec
une râpe à fromage ou nos souffrances
pour peu de résultats
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous n'avez rien compris à l'épidémie
allez vous qui avez rien n'est pas le
facteur il allait de mourir du canadien
c'est l'âge de 75 ans ce soir ils ont
accusé parmi les personnes qui risquent
d'aller en réanimation sujet mais nous
faisons nous j'espère qu'on vous l'être
après pas mais n'est-il pas
j'ai quand même s'il existe des
traitements même si vous n'y a pas lié
par ses traités
c'est là s'ils avaient à des traitements
efficaces vous pensez réellement que
c'est la chloroquine ivermectine ou la
poudre de perlimpinpin pas marché on en
sera encore là là je peux vous dire dans
quel et plusieurs de mes amis qui ont eu
des femmes vivent dehors de mes amis ok
oui moi j'aime alimente au bled elle a
eu une fois un peu de curcuma déjà
certains moments où on m'a dit sarah
arrête parce que tu prends beaucoup trop
les choses à coeur et que ça te touche
pour réellement donc on me l'a dit à
plusieurs fonctions
je suis complètement jeu sans être
passée complètement autre chose
wayne is he man important mais c'est
extrêmement maintenant je suis très
triste comme ça et parce qu'en fait
c'est qu'en faire des choses que les
gens savent pas en fait fait que
d'échappement charte en divorce
on m'a contre-attaqué sur des
harcèlements alors que vraiment pour le
coup j'ai rien à voir dedans et quand tu
t'exprimes tout le monde s'acharne sur
toi on insulte sur des lives honteux on
appuie dessus sans même savoir le
pourquoi du comment et en fait à
plusieurs reprises je vais pas vous
mentir je suis tombé même pour riblon
pas et j'ai envoyé un message à ces
personnes en leur disant en fêtard et
voir mon mode de vie je vais vous dire
car manger m'ouvrir les veines en fait
parce que j'arrive plus j'arrive plus à
nos pommes sa g entendre juste parce que
j'ai un caractère qui est assez fort
donc on se dit elle peut tout assumer sa
maman bon je pensais que il y avait un
exemple qui était suivie par les jeunes
mais j'ai non seulement en fait les
jeunes ne prouve ne nous apprennent rien
de ces émissions mais en plus les
acteurs de ces émissions ses émissions
là sont tellement comment dirais-je des
voiliers et des voix les personnes qu'on
en arrive à avoir des gens qui pleurent
sur ce plateau si vous voulez enfin
alexis en plus de nous rendre compte
ça rend malheureux les appelait les gens
qui y sont mais alors à quoi l'intérêt
il faisait un apport très sûr moi d'en
louer ils ont appelé diverses personnes
dont marlène schiappa parce qu'il était
sûrement venu en algérie alors on lui
pose une question sur moi va pas parler
d'autre chose
donc forcément plus elle m'expliqua oui
merci à plusieurs mois parce que c'était
il ya très longtemps il valérie il
démarre en disant est ce que c'est bien
le sujet du moment et whip aux quatre
questions ce qui n'est pas le sujet du
moment six hartmann a été non
sincèrement il a été archi lourd à moi
j'écoutais jusqu à l île a été archi
lourd vraiment et à chaque fois elle le
renvoyer dans l'est dans les cordes il a
été très lourd en plus ce qui dérange en
fait cyril si vous c'est ça c'est cette
idée si vous vous toucher au pré carré
d'une certaine élite de journalistes et
anton prénommé ya plein de journalistes
qui le prennent très bien y en a qu à
bien les plantes intelligent le prennent
bien mais d'autres prennent très belle
en disant c'est nina qui va co présenter
le débat c'est vrai qu'on est dans le
même cas
tous les soirs on se retrouve avec des
doses de vaccin astrazeneca qu'on va
joti mode brégeon là il ya un travail de
communication à faire
pourquoi vous n'ouvrez pas par exemple
en seine saint denis un département
jeunes qui en demandent à quoi tous les
jeunes de seine-saint-denis ne peuvent
pas se faire vacciner d'ici je le pense
que d'ici quelques jours ou quelques
semaines en tout cas au fur et à mesure
qu'on avance ça va s'ouvrir la
vaccination elle va s'ouvrir vous
l'avais dit il ya quelque part une bonne
nouvelle en tout cas si on veut regarder
le verre à moitié plein c'est qu'il ya
deux semaines j'étais sur ce plateau et
on se plaignait collectivement du fait
qu'il n'y avait pas suffisamment de
doses et que on attendait que les
vaccins arrivent en france aujourd'hui
les doses
elles arrivent petit à petit qu'est-ce
qui vous ont dit on n'a pas parlé avec
les policiers en fin de compte moi
j'étais en train de faire les photos que
vous avez vu des policiers qui sortait
et mon associé sortie s'est mis devant
l'immeuble à fumer une cigarette avec le
masque quoi enlever le masque effet à
fumer sa cigarette et entendit commence
à nous casser les couilles que ça n'a
tout simplement il ya une règle pour
vous bruno romain qui connaissait bien
la voilà à la police
oui mais s'agit-il c'est un fugitif oui
mais aussi direction fugitif mais sachez
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut avoir
voilà un peu si vous voyez christian
quesada ça pourrait le faire oui je ne
le font pas écoutez c'est la justice qui
décidera ce qu'ils se feront pas moi je
vous dis la vérité
l'histoire n'est pas claire se
libérerait excusez moi vous salue
spécialisés des faits divers alors vous
êtes spécialiste et cacahuètes
franchement je le verrai je vous dis la
vérité on a on n'a pas d'info sur le
truc si le mec il est sur wii les
fugitifs pour il est paraît il il faut
faire un avis de recherche mais c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est ce qu'on
appelle les mythomanes les gens qui
croient effectivement dans leur mensonge
alors il n'y a pas ça rentre pas dans
des catégories psychiatrique même dans
le dsm qui est le gros livre de l' oms
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
concernant la psychiatrie terre que ce
sont les troubles relationnels
narcissique avec des gens qui sont dans
la toute puissance qui se pensent
totalement différent et c'est quelqu'un
qui m'apparaît en tout cas paraître pour
être présent sur les plateaux télé cher
tout et n'importe quoi et surtout faire
ensuite perpétue l'on parlait lui c'est
ça et donc il est là dedans
vous pensez que c'est un coin et ses
limites oui pour moi oui c'est purement
narcissique il a raison le monsieur
bernard montiel
je perdais est en fait il aurait préparé
justement cette fuite peut être aussi
pour refaire parler de vie d'une autre
manière
mais comme l'a fait dupont de ligonnès
au 10 mai comparé match on nous donne de
l'espoir
ah oui on est tous devenus fous là mais
on peut pas vivre indéfiniment
je veux dire on donne de l'espoir ce
gouvernement
merci genty président de la république
nous donner de l'espoir moi j'aurais
préféré qu'ils nous donnent des
solutions
fecteau mais elle me donne de l'espoir
vous êtes tous devenus fous
j'avais cru un moment quant à dylan et
vous allez perdre adil rami qui foncent
dessus ça s'étudie fait un moment que je
vois le logo de renault sas par travis
et j'hésite à deux choix soit fait sur
la voiture des loyers et au soir des
élections que tu montes sur le plateau
de la voiture et avec la vitesse pour
les polémiques sur le capot et j'ai
tourné vers le capot le dernier jeu
passer le temps dans le comptage gérer
sur le village et d'y observer une
paroisse qui la pressent la part du ps
qu'il accédait en même temps j'ai des
jeux